un granjero cosecha 531 jitomates y
puede vender 176 de ellos en tres días
ya que la cantidad de jitomate se de
crem en está en 176 cuántos jitomates
que eran al final de esos tres días
bueno
comenzamos con 531 jitomates
esencialmente vamos a restar estos 176 a
los 531 que teníamos originalmente aquí
lo voy a hacer de este lado de manera
tradicional y aquí a la derecha les voy
a mostrar lo que sucede con más detalle
paso a paso voy a escribir aquí
connotación desarrollada estos 531 531
es igual a tener 500
+ 1
y al restar 176 tenemos menos 100
- 70
- 6
aquí tenemos las unidades las decenas y
las centenas igual aquí aquí están las
unidades las decenas y las centenas y
así va a ser más fácil saber qué sucede
cuando tomamos prestado o reagrupamos de
este lado izquierdo vemos que este 1 es
menor que 6 así que tenemos que
reagrupar los otros elementos para poder
hacer la resta vamos directamente a las
decenas de aquí vamos a reagrupar o
pedir prestado si vemos en este lado
derecho aquí de este 30 tomamos
prestados 10 nos van a quedar 20 y esos
10 que tomamos prestado los vamos a
agregar aquí de manera que en lugar de
tener 1 no vamos a tener 11 si lo vemos
del lado izquierdo decimos que a este 2
decimos que a este 3 le tomamos prestado
un 1 de manera que nos queda un 2 y este
1 se convierte en 11 cuando yo iba en la
escuela decíamos que tomábamos prestado
un 1 del 3 y ese 1 lo pega vamos al otro
lado pero lo que sucede es que tomamos
10 de 30 nos quedan 20 y esos diez los
agregamos a esta parte de las unidades
y ahora si podemos restar 11 menos 65
aquí me queda 5 y este lado pues también
me queda 5
ahora vamos a pasar al lugar de las
decenas tenemos 2 que es menor que 7 o
lo que es lo mismo 20 que es menor que
70 por lo que tenemos que agregar más al
lugar de las decenas vamos a las antenas
a buscar valores que reagrupar qué pasa
si 500 le quito 100 pues me va a quedar
aquí 400 y esto sí nos voy a agregar
aquí a este 20 de manera que me va a
quedar 120 de este lado a este 5 le
quito 1 no me va a quedar 4 y ese 1 lo
pongo aquí junto al 2 de manera que me
quede 12 y ahora bueno ya puedo hacer la
resta 12 menos siete va a ser 5 o lo que
es lo mismo 120 menos 70 va a ser igual
a 50
50 33 más ese 5 sigue siendo el 50
porque está en el lugar de las escenas
finalmente llegamos a las centenas
tenemos 400 menos 104 106 mayor que 100
podemos hacer estar está directamente
400 menos 100 nos queda 300
4 - 1 estrés por lo que nos queda 355 y
ya hemos terminado al granjero le quedan
355 jitomates al final de el tercer día